hallo willkommen
zum in ihrer reportage zu der
konversionsmaßnahmen wo hohe wellen
geschlagen hat muss ich sehr geehrter
kommentare zuvor geklagt viel lob will
kritik wir gern vorbeikommen terry und
wir reden noch mit der
religionswissenschaftler adriano monte
foods co wohl eine reportage expert
vorkommt der markt fragt wie kann man
mit dem smartphone das ganze firmen ohne
dass es auffällt ist das nicht
offensichtlich ja an china nicht also
wie nach der kopf und hals handy in der
hand kam und ihm ein hitzetag sap habe
ich immer das handy in der hand und ich
wohne luftfahrer obwohl die ganzen
gefühle jetzt falle den hof bbc ja
verrückt sagt sie dass nicht alles nur
weil ihr selber zurückkommt und selber
sagt dass seine homosexualität ein
problem ist ich meine wenn jemand kommt
muss man dann sagen dein problem ist
keines finde dich einfach mit deiner
homosexualität ab ja ich finde so also
iran während der recherche mit der
psychologin geredet und was wäre denn
antwort oder die herangehensweise wo man
studiert psychologie studierte
psychologin und sehen genau gesagt es
ist nett idee zum noch einen grund von
ra sexuelle orientierungssuche sondern
noch 100 grund wieso einem zerstört und
es ist ein großer unterschied
mariam peter fragt herz aktuelle
recherche den orchideen im umfeld
geändert also ich habe schon sehr viel
mit meinem engsten privaten umfeld
darüber geredet weil es hätten wir schon
mit genau über nacht will wenn du detox
und dann wirklich denkt das lied wurde
hock und andré war wirklich glauben
wirklich dass kühlen und mein gott ich
kann man deutlich
hervor zauberer das hat mir mega mega
bit of gemacht also für mich jetzt
selber kann relativ gut können quasi mit
geschäftlichen
geschäft und privat tyler und deshalb
hätte das jetzt für mich irgendwie
identitätskrise muskel ist überhaupt
nicht ich bin mir sehr sicher in ihrer
sexuellen direkt pudelwohl karin seit es
wäre doch noch interessant gewesen wenn
du keine probleme in der kindheit
erfunden hätte und selbstsicher
aufgetreten wäre hätte sich dann die
therapeutin was aus den fingern gezogen
das ist sehr gefragt während der
dreharbeiten aber der brite in der
therapie stellvertretend für all die
junger menschen oder ältere menschen
nach der therapie geld und das wirklich
wendt und denn meistens auch als drama
hand und vielleicht auch schon kühl hält
auffällig könnte dass er der modelica
die haben mit banner mit geredet wo so
therapie durchgemacht hat und quasi ihre
geschichte selber gefasst und muss dem
geschichte von guido gemacht zum etwas
seltsame gerät mit seiner mensch macht
die christoph morgenthaler fragt warum
lassen sich jugendliche oder erwachsene
auf das ein also wenn jedes standard ist
das große druck vor der client zum
beispiel oder vor der gesellschaft wird
in der schweiz ja ich es einfach noch
immer spezielle wenn man die täter
sexuell ist
also ich habe großen druck vor sich wenn
nicht anders sie als alliander also dass
da kann ihm eigenen fahrräder er ist im
moment wo man das reagiert man mit sechs
mit tropfen oder und das buch zieht zum
dass wir akzeptieren wenn man dann von
der therapie gehört denkmal acombo wäre
das thema will eigentlich weder die also
gar nicht aber es hätte oder kommentar
abgeben das quasi hat beantwortet hat
1988 als 18-jähriger wurde ich auf
nachdruck für meine familie zum arzt
gedrängt wegen meiner homosexualität der
arzt hat mir eine hormontherapie
verabreicht das hat dazu geführt dass
ich einen falschen weg eingeschlagen
habe und erst mit 40 jahren hatte ich
dann den mut gehabt um mein coming-out
zu starten heute über 30 jahre später
hilft mir ein toller psychiater überall
das wegzukommen und zu verarbeiten was
geschehen ist und selber zu mir zu
stehen ich glaube der kommentar zeigt
gut wie es überhaupt so ein kunde das
oberthema behandelt und was das denn
gemacht aber jetzt eine reportage mit
dem expert geredet
religionswissenschaftler adriano monte
foods co erhöht sich mit freikirchen
homosexualität beschäftigt ich möchte
jetzt mit ihm genau über diese frage
reden schon kommentarbox hey wenn die
leute svend lernt sie doch leben und
leben lassen adriano wieso das denn
genau wichtig zum ethernet leben und
leben lassen und zum über das leder aus
der chemie regelt vier gründe sind darum
dass man klug und aber nie zu leben und
leben lassen laute 12 die
wissenschaftliche gesellschaft politisch
der grund warum nicht leben und leben
lassen ist dass die konversionsmaßnahmen
darf ich sie also sie nutzen nicht nur
menü konnte sich der schatten auch dann
fingen die sorge das wort grund ist man
muss auch fragen wie konnte sondern
veränderungswünsche stand mit einem
menschen oder die maßnahme anspruch
nehmen und damit als gesamtgesellschaft
oder mitverantwortung der g2
gesellschaftspolitische probleme hey wo
liebe zu europa mit leben und leben
lassen ist eine sich sie nach bislang
deutschland und frankreich hey ein sitz
deutschland schon ausgesetzt lamento die
allergie konversionsmaßnahmen
verbietet frankreich hat jetzt das
gesetz verabschiedet und mittels gesehen
das von deutschland schon organisationen
schweiz gelandet ist heute probiert hier
fuß fassen und hier wird's praktizieren
mit konversionsmaßnahmen und die
vermutete sie die romandie in der
westschweiz anderswo passiert nachdem
französische organisation in frankreich
legte praktizieren und wägen die stadt
ihn dass man als gesellschaft halle 0 m
- schweiz 1 ins land werde in meti von
europa oder tourismus entsteht wo legen
die lande event jährige jähriges
ungefähre geschleppt und je nachher mit
synchronisation in verbindung bringt
minister mit allen wolken und
weltgewandt ist gesellschaftspolitisch
von federow legitim ist drücken dem
ersten juli vor dem jahre
therapeutin psychotherapeut in die
lästige für die gesetzliche
grundversicherung der krankenkasse
abrechnen und dumm finden ist es legitim
ist über gedanken machen was ist
seine form von operativem wünsche oder
zu braucht werden weil jede sexuelle
delikte wenn wir ja schon bizarr und
wenig seriös die konversionsmaßnahmen
folgekosten verursachen sie schaut euch
sie dürfen
oder dem vorhaben so komisch gmail app
store zum beispiel ihr beitrag zum thema
umpolung war unausgewogen warum haben
sie niemand zu wort kommen lassen der
positive erfahrung gemacht hat also anno
tobak
wunder wo quasi seiten haye der therapie
hätte mir funktioniert und haben den
atomic von david haye ich habe lang
behauptet dass die therapie bei mir
funktioniert hat und jetzt eben immer
jetzt du hast bce sich in das thema
mensch aus so lüth was sagst du zu
dämmen es geht tatsächlich
lobte dass die konversionsmaßnahmen
benedikt heraushält binz ehe von
homosexuellen wollte dass sie bisexuell
ihren die ewigkeit kontrakte ich habe
mit überaus mehrere dutzend fonds für
fische generation objekt und tatsächlich
ist es so dass eine genaue nach einem
ins gespräch und auch frage stellt was
bedeutet dvd kate das bedeutete für die
orientierte kraxelt der haymoz sollte
von einer ludwigshafener
exzesse minister sie kenne empfehlen die
gmbh homosexuelle immer so aber ja
strategie erklärt wenig mit den
empfindungen markt kam um gar ausmachen
die standzeiten dass sie eigentlich
unglückliches stoppte die hier heute mit
sprach den ratsuchenden vermittelt
werden wie sie die flure in schach
halten und wie sie
probieren aber nach haiti sexuell ionen
technik muss zwar eine skate frauen des
haupt finanz
homosexuelle praktiken wie der nächste
der nächste kommentare beatrice wache
ein völliger des die freikirchler in den
dreck zu ziehen
also das muss ich wirklich sagen ich
wirklich nicht idee xii haben vorher vor
der reportage nicht so viel über
freikirche küsst hand relativ viel
drüber recherchiert wird die client okay
es geht mir gefiel verschiedene
freikirchen in der schweiz die
freikirche da andere sicht auf die sache
und ganz sicher hängt
also negative ich stelle gegenüber
homosexualität oder in italien stieg das
um homosexualität kann heilen aber es
gibt halt leg und in eine kanadische
studie stande dass 67 prozent von deiner
konversionsmaßnahmen passieren hat ihm
eine freikirchliche setting deshalb hat
es auch nennt wir haben das eine der
frühesten luftkrieg war der mark zahlen
schrieb du hast zusammen mit matt
darüber gesprochen dass ein verbot von
konversions therapien ineffektiv wäre
nun eröffnet sich damit die frage wie
wir eine veränderung in die richtung des
heutigen wissensstandes erreichen können
also sicher so oder so es ist aus der
politik schon
quasi seite oder hey ist verboten nützt
ihr menü zum verband war sie das alles
nun untergrund und dann ist nur mehr
versteckt was sagst du putzt das gebot
oder macht das 10 oder macht das gar
nicht so seriöse wissenschaft wird heute
mit einem foul gebremst carsten studt
nachdenken was wir passieren sonst geht
es für sie und da diese film stichtag
zum ende ist es ja was für dort wird die
konversions maßnahme stellte youtube und
das glaube ich
ist sondern braucht natürlich auch als
starkes signal
besonders für betroffene
er besitze wenn gedanken gemacht hey
willst volker physiotherapie auf dieser
maßnahme signal achtung das ist
wahrscheinlich das verbot gibt
es zum mensch das stylische
organisationen in der schweiz lebenden
schweizers oppositionshochburg hama
hatte die praktika bieten praktiziert
wer das weiß ich verachte vor aber das
wort wieder zu frau carla die kali
beratung und seelsorge beide
probieren der akkreditierten das
nachdiplomstudium an der eidgenössisch
anerkannte therapie muss wie strom oder
er habe krankenkassen abzurechnen
aktivität überdies endete die therapie
aus normale
validierung therapie wie der anbieter
das wird
erfolgte vor sie und was man muss dann
kann ich das verbot werden niemand
dahinter um die studie des internet in
amerika zu mieten ruf englisch mit
piraterie mit der private kontakt in der
ohl iphone oder hast du schon thema
nachhaltiger maßnahmen zu unterziehen
das ist ja natürlich das überhaupt
möglich eine des teams das ist schade
fragen an die hand damit
danke vielmals der zeugnisausgabe
gemacht
tags darauf auf druck seiner
gesprochenen dialekte und so spöttisch
wenn es so käme gezwungen die er so
originalgetreu wie möglich
nach sprecher und wo nie der therapie
kopf bin ich die sprecher von
analytikern
irgendwie er will sie irgendwie 1
das wäre das kind zum teil und das ist
mir wichtig sitzung das widrige er will
dass ich irgendwie schon aber
bist wie sie und professionalität ruft
zeigt viele herr naujoks als betroffener
wo findet auch in verstell ich meine
website beschrieben vor dem video
verlinkt und ewig vor der reportage e
mail an arm und kritik nagt aber die
kommentare übrigens heimkehr einen
wichtigen gesellschaftlichen beitrag
leisten es ist wichtig dass man das
irgendwie auch erwähnt also das
landeskirchenamt heilsarmee viele gute
sachen machen das möchte absolut nicht
bestritten das ist so aber im filmmuseum
der umgang mit sexueller orientierungen
kann und deshalb finde ich selber schon
noch wichtig dass man über das redet
will der umgang hat einfach oft nur mega
potenzial und da muss man einfach nur
bitter
und wenn es schon nutzer diskussionen
führt innerhalb einer organisation
heizte potenzial zum zukünftiger schade
bis auch hilfesuchend zu verhindern
shake baby seit zum schluss noch super
schlusswort herr ja das ist mir nur
wichtig dass norma zeiger ich glaube
wirklich dass die nyt böses meinen sie
wissen es einfach eine bessere was chaos
rädisch aber eine klärung immerhin und
ich hoffe dass da willen zur aufklärung
betreibt in der ganzen schweiz und dass
man vermehrt darüber redet über das
ganze thema ok derzeit von der kommentar
dank viel viel mal wenn du da bist und
der sf dok account abbonieren dass es
mir gefreut und lockt er noch bei videos
an